quem nunca se apaixonou uma palestra
técnica e atira primeiro vídeo que
normalmente é amor à primeira vista como
foi o caso
eu posso dizer que é uma paixão
absolutamente duradoura
as tarefas são os setores que a idéia e
traduzidas de uma demanda de uma legião
de fãs é che e pediu para traduzidas e
olha compartilhadas com seus amigos seus
colegas de sua família
no caso do brasil o trabalho de tradução
é fundamental uma vez que apenas 5% das
pessoas de acordo com levantamento do
proteste alçou 5% ou menos influência em
vez de uma cura assim o caso foi a chave
de nossa dívida abre uma porta e se caso
de esperança a milhões de brasileiros
atualmente nós somos quase 30.000
tradutores voluntários o mundo é seu
eles são brasileiros para 116 sintomas e
com quase sempre 26 mil produções feitas
até o momento mas nós não apenas saúde
oss como também percebemos as palestras
feiras e eventos com estes aqui há nove
transmissão é importantíssimo não só
para lembrar suas
fc do mundo mas com para permitir
pessoas com deficiência auditiva
consigam acompanhar o conteúdo das
palestras
quando a palestra não é nada em inglês
no meu caso que ela em português
primeiro é transcrita no idioma original
para depois é revertida para ver e do
inglês é que ela é traduzida para ser
mais línguas
inicialmente o ted com o próprio
logotipo indica abordará temas como
tecnologia do que no verso em fat que é
o ea gente pode traduzir como diversão e
design ao qual se a feder
normalmente as palestras
agora há uma infinidade de assuntos que
não deseja excedentes objetivo política
negócios e veneno orizo até natura nós
temos por exemplo as obras de
shakespeare
outra das minhas paixões
aquilo que a ex-agente o tema é esse o
motivo é aquele que a gente tem não só
como também da redução da jornada do
trabalho humano do meu presidente
educativos curtinhos acessíveis até
crianças muito pequenas
não faço isso não só porque traduzirem
uma mais chão paixão uma palavra chave
no caminho não só porque o prazer de
conduzir esta sala é essa sejam sedex a
ser top série d não só o que eu aprendo
muito com elas
e aqui eu lembro que tradutor é um
leitor do ibge a não só que na véspera
na família será joão pessoa bastante
ansiosa não só que é iniciante
às vezes eu tive uma transição mais meia
hora em hora que o relógio se passaram
duas três horas acontece uma vez com ele
e com o santos
não só porque algumas pessoas
fantásticas como estou conhecendo aqui
nesse evento pessoas inspiradoras
mas o que eu acho que eu acho que vale a
pena é usar meu excedentes ou contigo em
iniciativas com esta
segundo o filósofo é defron
amy se abrisse promissão o homem na vida
é da música si mesmo e tornar se aquilo
que ele é potencialmente eu venho de
educação é fundamental pra isso e nem o
dono da educação é fundamental para que
pessoas menos privilegiadas com os
privilégios ou excluídas da nossa
sociedade possam se inserir de forma de
na nossa sociedade e quando eu penso em
trabalho voluntário mec é o mesmo que é
o trabalho de doação seja doasse eu
tenho seja o acesso ao conhecimento
sai do ar o objeto é justamente o seu
trabalho voluntário e 5 escolha linha
com a decisão minha
eu tenho de fazê lo da melhor forma o
cibio e tem hoje comprometer do ar o
tempo que o sombra é diferente no ar as
obras nos resta é complexa e não só
conhecer principalmente a nossa produção
bem feita
há sempre muito trabalho muita sós de
gestação influente prazerosa de nenê
assim o angustiado que o melhor que faça
ele sempre pode fazer melhor porque isso
pode ser melhorar quase é que eu preciso
lembrar que a grande maioria dos nossos
voluntários não é profissional isso é
muito
se digo adeus maioria mas apesar disso
nós primamos pela qualidade das nossas
produções não só respeitar o palestrante
mas respeita a quem mexe para garantir
essa qualidade
todas as traduções e transmissões passa
por uma revisão feita pelos próprios
voluntários para finalmente ela ser
reprovadas no em um escort neiton o
coordenador de linguagem ou como a gente
chama por um rc
no caso do brasil do português mas o
português de portugal
nós temos 10 deve ser nos faz eu
gostaria de citar é que nominalmente lei
história
nós temos aí lembra nós temos a marca de
ceni
a cláudia e eu temos os nossos rapazes
que só foi leonardo gustavo
o túlio ou por soja eo rafael é essa
obsessão que eu tenho uma educação
na verdade ela tem a ver não só com o
brasil que digam lá uma crise profunda
política é que a educação é relegar a
segundo plano mas sim a ver com a minha
própria história pessoal meu pai que
hoje é 62 anos se fosse vivo ao chão os
primário
apesar disso sabia desde
em fazer as quatro operações matemáticas
muito bem e o sonho dele pois sempre
poder estudar a lei estudado e fazer um
dos filhos estudassem
por isso ele devemos fazer o nosso
nacional da aeo beiras resolveu se mudar
com os seus quatro filhos é para muitos
estados a maior cidade do norte de minas
e montes claros o meu marido tinha nem
do seu comércio na sua loja e orelhas e
o seu sítio estabeleceu também com
comerciantes
ele tinha um pequeno hotel e
tecnológicos presença de tinha pressão
nos no entanto em 1964
houve uma grande exceção do brasil teve
nessa recessão e outras razões o meu pai
foi à falência e perder absolutamente
tudo
ele ficou realmente sem nada nós e nada
nos seus os móveis velhos uns idiomas
segundo o mda do seu fracasso econômico
meu pai decidiu após pagar suas dívidas
se voltar para belo horizonte com uma
mão na frente ou atrás o bebê gostávamos
dizer
em belo horizonte a minha mais o sinal
de tarados imaginar a lei de seu affair
jogos paraguai
o buraco é um excelente brasileiro
juntos ultimamente ela resolveu redondos
queijo para vender tão grande um dos
anos na minha casa onde que foi
literalmente ió diga se de passagem nos
negócios foi a de que esses senhores
anos e tal é é a pena a gente não ter
que comer muitas vezes não tenho que
discutir uma coisa meu pai não abrir mão
é que nós continuássemos a estudar
e assim foi feito sem dúvida porque de
acordo com dados da pesquisa nacional
por amostra de domicílios
na faixa dos quarenta e oito anos aos 60
anos o brasil apenas 32% das pessoas de
escolaridade maior do que 15 fundamental
e essa obsessão e se fácil essa paixão
túnel martim da educação
parecia-nos menores gestos
meu pai sempre me colocar de pé os 17
anos de idade
naquela época a gente não pediu qualquer
visita em casa
eu sou é nas palavras
hoje pensando que isso de ser se mais
espanta visitas à paróquia da banda sem
saber
enfim eis nos meus irmãos conseguiram se
soltar mas conseguimos mais do que isso
hoje nós conseguimos dar aos nossos
filhos condições bem melhores do que é
assim nós tivemos e aqui eu falo pra
minha maior paixão na vida eu tenho
muitos outros dois filhos daniel e joão
henrique
os pais nunca conquistou uma cadeira
cada jornal pra mim mas para quem eu fiz
questão de todas as noites histórias
dormir leitura sempre foi um prazer para
mim e para os meus filhos
coincidente com a dispensa ou não
quatro de nós meus irmãos nos tornar os
professores a educação sendo incoerente
em algum momento da vida e um dos seus
irmãos e vai ficar assim absolutamente
fantástico ea tiggo é ser revolucionário
que ele é aplicar na educação dos alunos
a sua própria escola
a única mensagem que eu posso desejar
que hoje é que nós precisamos fazer é
educação obsessão conscientes e
obcecados com a educação
apesar das condições adversas apesar dos
desgovernos nosso país
a educação tem de ser uma prioridade
dentro da nossa casa ea minha paixão com
iniciativas ou pede em anter justamente
pelo fato de o fed assim o meu pai o seu
jeitão simples nos inspirou
assim hoje eu fui inspirada com esses
palestrantes maravilhosos
o ted nos inspira a espalhar idéias que
nos fazem acreditar que apesar de tudo
nós podemos